and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review jackass 3d movie I've
ever seen in my life
history bumming this is boilers there's
this movie called jackass and everybody
thought it was gonna bomb and get bombed
oh right as in bad box office records
that needs to be good and so they need a
sequin and everybody thought was gonna
Bob but in fun what everybody thought
was going to happen that also needs to
be good it sounds a certain movie is out
and everybody's like what else is
showing this weekend a Bruce Willis
action film with Helen Mirren and John
Malkovich ok jack has win so likelihood
that this book is gonna be a huge hit
which is kind of surprising because the
plant is very hard to follow Abby really
hits these mentally handicapped guys who
are trying to find the meaning of life
if I can't deny hurting each other
I did that once it hurt these guys get
together and do these incredible stunts
like playing baseball with your penises
getting trampled by a buffalo farting on
bubbles
every through an obstacle course of a
series big deal that's what me and my
bum friends do every week except the
tasers are usually from the police and
they have no bug friends but that
doesn't stop me from participating
anyway I always win and the prize is a
silent void of emptiness so this is the
first chance will need to be shot in 3d
and it's awesome I've always wanted to
see all that urine and feces but I doubt
that you know you know what I see pretty
much every day those Cub Scouts can be
soo me better what I like about the
movie is it actually lives up to its
title the first two films didn't have
any jackasses in it if a movie is called
Jack yet I expect to see donkeys and
this film actually has one you see they
actually tried to pin the tail on a
donkey and a donkey I didn't try pinning
the tail on a real donkey once he died
of cancer
don't let are you probably wondering why
these people hurt themselves so much and
laugh at the end will because they're
masochist that's right the guys from
jackass are masochists they don't show
it but every single time they're done
with it stunt they go into the corner
and start jerking off wheat maybe they
do show that but it's sold out of
contact
all these films are always really big
hits I was thinking maybe they can do
some crossovers like maybe the sound of
music meets jackass jackass frankly my
dear I don't give a flying dildo oh hey
a plain doodle or maybe Pride and
Prejudice meets jackass so she can tell
Jake history these are really really
good V but I say why not push a step
further let's go check it for thee
literally have feces and urine flying
out of the audience it's okay I'll
provide the feces in urine I breed them
on a farm and maybe then the Jackass
crew will finally let me be a part of
their team
I've been sending you so many videos how
come you never responded back I know the
videos they don't attempt any the stunts
that's why I treat brand-new stunts like
setting myself on fire and jumping on a
trampoline I told it me setting myself
on fire while jumping on a trampoline
created no and all I ever got back was
one stinking letter saying seek out this
guy named mental help what is this meant
to help God anyway hey if someone can
make millions of dollars by hurting
themselves and making people laugh I
think America needs to seek this mental
health guy or maybe mental help should
just give up and have some fun either
way here's to not being a full fight
what I watch this is jittery bouncing
well at least I'm enjoy the Jackass team
just the smell of me is gonna make them
vomit